Last time, no butter or eggs
were allowed.
Can they do it vegan style?
Rahul continued to impress.
That chickpea was unbelievable.
But it was Kim-Joy's
bold approach...
I love the colours.
..that won her Star Baker.
Despite Ruby's collapse...
Oh, man.
..Jon just couldn't convert
to veganism...
Can we have a kebab week soon?
..and left the tent.
It's been amazing, it really has.
This week, it's the quarterfinals...
SHE BREATHES DEEPLY
..and a Bake Off first -
Danish week.
Ha-ha! Ooh!
A Scandi signature...
Ouch.
..a tricky technical...
The whole thing is burned.
..and a great Danish showstopper,
culminating in a Viking onslaught...
A-Argh!
It's just burnt,
you left it in the oven too long.
I don't deserve to be here any
more. Oh, God.
..as the bakers battle
for a place in the semifinals.
That was a bit brutal.
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
Sandi, I'm so excited,
it's Danish week!
I know! What are the chances?
I'm Danish,
and Bake Off decide to have
their first ever Danish week.
Hey, listen, thanks for getting
the costumes.
I just want everything to be perfect
for you.
I've even come up with some jokes.
Oh, yeah?
Danish jokes. OK.
Why did the Viking buy an old boat?
I don't know.
Because he couldn't afford
a new one.
No, he couldn't A-FJORD a new one.
That's even better!
How do Vikings send messages?
I don't know.
Morse code. No, NORSE code.
That is fantastic.
Go on, say "It's Danish week"
in Danish.
SHE SPEAKS DANISH
Brilliant. How do you even do that?
I just speak. I love that beard.
What a week to lose your tweezers.
It's week eight,
and only five bakers remain.
In tribute to Jon, who left last
week, the bakers have decided
to leave their Viking wear behind
and don Hawaiian shirts.
It's the blooming quarterfinals.
Let's do this. Game on.
Come on.
I think Kim-Joy,
she's the baker to beat.
She's a dark horse.
So, yeah, little cute Kim-Joy,
she's like,
"I'm going to make you the
best cake ever."
I'm all prepared, yeah.
There could be a Scandi drama.
What do I know about Danish baking?
Erm...
I've never done Danish baking
before.
I think...
Is "croshos" Danish?
Kosher? Crochons.
Croissants? Croissants. Hmm...
Hi, bakers. Wow, look at you!
Did not get the memo
about this week.
It's like a Beach Boys convention.
It's Danish week.
Now, for your Signature Challenge
today, the judges would love you
to bake a rye bread, and from it,
create two perfectly executed,
delicious open sandwiches.
They're called smorrebrod.
Open sandwiches,
which must be presented alongside
your rye loaf.
The judges would like you to make
your own personal rye bread recipe,
but, you know,
it had better be good.
You have three-and-a-half hours.
On your marks... Get set...
SHE SPEAKS DANISH
The traditional Danish rye bread
used for smorrebrod
is dark and dense
and takes 24 hours to create.
The bakers must be inventive to
produce a loaf
with a similar texture and flavour.
So one of my really good friends
is Danish.
It is one of the hardest languages,
because you have to...
..R-R-R!
You know, make your throat, like...
Smorrebrod, smorrebrod.
Smorrebrod. Smorrebrod, smorrebrod.
When I say that, I sound like I'm
trying to be Welsh.
Smorrebrod.
Now, basically, what it is,
it's an open sandwich.
The base of the open sandwich
is rye.
Lots and lots of seeds in it,
on top of which -
strong flavours,
normally pickled or smoked.
Big hitters.
Oh!
I think the trick is beauty
combined with simplicity.
It must be a little work of art on a
small piece of very thin rye bread.
This is the quarterfinals now.
Any problems, I'll be on them.
Good morning, Rahul. Morning.
So, it's quarterfinals, Rahul.
I don't want to think about that,
I'm just thinking it's
a normal week.
Well, we want to know about
your open sandwiches.
There is going to be
one with smoked salmon,
I'm going to serve it with
remoulade. It's basically carrot,
celeriac and shallots,
chopped up really nicely,
then reduced down in a pickling
liqueur. Little bit of curry powder,
mix it with mayonnaise, and then I'm
going to pickle some cucumber
as well, then lemon, a few asparagus
spears and some dill leaves.
I'm going to make some home-made
cheese, and do pickles -
candied beetroot, golden beetroot,
normal beetroot -
and arrange it on the top.
Your time's up, now you've
described that! Sorry?
Somewhere under all the home-made
toppings,
Rahul is attempting to pull off
a traditional dense and seedy
rye bread, which takes the Danes
24 hours to produce.
See, see, this is what happens.
I think it's just getting there.
Sandwiches have names, so you ought
to name your sandwiches.
Yeah, mine's really boring
at the minute.
There's a very famous sandwich
shop
where they have a sandwich
named after my father.
So there's a Claus Toksvig sandwich.
No way!
Yeah! How cool is that?
So you could have
the Hollywood sandwich or...
No, OK. No, you don't want that.
Ruby would rather name her
smorrebrod after a treadmill
than Paul.
Inspired by her favourite post-gym
snacks, she is creating
a Mediterranean breakfast
and a tandoori chicken lunch.
Her base will be a lightly seeded
rye bread.
How much flour?
What's the weight of flour?
I've gone 200 for each.
Water, how much water?
250.
250? Millilitres of water, yeah.
No other liquid in there at all?
250 to 400?
Oh, God, why?
That's just how I practised.
Should I put more in?
OK. Why, what should I...?
What would you...?
I'm not going to tell you, am I?!
NOEL: Making one rye bread
is tricky enough...
It's like super-duper sticky.
..but to stand out from the rest,
Briony is taking a massive risk by
attempting two doughs.
You get, you know, the usual nausea
that kicks in about now,
the blind fear of having to
bake bread for Paul Hollywood.
You know, standard.
Briony is out to impress by
marbelling her dark and light doughs
into a decorative loaf.
She is spanning the EU for her
Danish sandwich toppings, with a
Spanish meat feast on one and
a West Country platter on the other.
It's all about the display for me,
this. Yeah, absolutely.
Well, they're both going to
look like little gardens.
The chorizo and the Iberico will be
in little flowers.
This is Briony the artist.
I'm going to have a tomato swan.
Tomato swan! Yeah, you wait.
OK, all right.
Thank you very much.
It's not terrifying at all having to
knead in front of Paul Hollywood.
Timing's critical,
so there's no more time to knead.
Need to prove it.
Rye dough can be tricky to prove.
The bakers must judge time
and temperature precisely.
Right, rise, my little pretty.
Too much, and the bread will lose
its tight rye texture.
Under prove,
and it'll be dense and stodgy.
Normally, I don't put it in
the proving drawer.
It's 30 degrees now.
Think I'll just reduce it slightly.
We're going to start cooking.
AMERICAN ACCENT: We got sweet
potato, we got normal potato,
we got fig jam,
we got beetroot smoking.
NORMAL VOICE: It's all happening,
it's all happening.
All the bakers have chosen
savoury toppings,
some more than others.
So just making some cheese,
as if I'm not mad enough.
But Manon is adding a little
sweetness to her smorrebrod.
It's just mascarpone
and Gorgonzola.
In France, we don't actually
eat cheese with sweet stuff.
I'm really excited about
these flavours,
because it's so cheesy and creamy
and delicious.
Mmm!
If there's any left,
Manon's cheese fest will be married
with fresh fruit.
She's taking a punt on a light rye
bread, and instead of using
a traditional tin, she's relying on
her trusty saucepan
for an artisan crust.
It's not going in a tin,
it's just going in that pan?
Yeah, mm-hm, so it's round.
When you put it in the pan,
does it actually reach the sides?
No. It doesn't,
it just sits in the middle? Yeah.
Any problems with the dough being
slightly raw in the middle?
That's why this is good.
And also, I tried to do it in the
tin, and it would not cook.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Once I saw those, it was all over.
Swan tomatoes.
Are you going to make
a radish goose?
Not today.
Leave it at swan tomatoes.
I wonder what Paul
will make of them.
I know. I think he's going to...
Cos he loves decoration,
small animals, girlie stuff.
Yeah, I mean, it's his
favourite thing ever, right?
He's in his trailer now...
Actually, as I was coming here, I
just peeked in through the window,
and he was in a tutu, and he was
doing a sort of
really weird drawing of a unicorn.
And then he pretended...
When he saw me, he threw away
the unicorn picture,
and he picked up a car magazine.
These are boiling,
I'll just give them...
Because I've got 26 seconds,
I want them to be hard-boiled,
because they've got to turn
into bumblebees.
So they can't be soft-boiled bees.
Kim-Joy's delicate boiled egg bees
will buzz amongst cheese flowers,
and an intricate cucumber and radish
fish will swim
above a seabed of
wholemeal sourdough.
So that's actually got quite a good
rise for a wholemeal bread.
I'm quite happy with that.
It's done all right.
It's been about...
Just under double, I think.
Oh, yeah. That'll do nicely.
I'm just going to knock it back.
Oh, dear me.
This is just not right.
My bread doesn't rise at all!
Did yours rise?
Did you put it in...?
Yeah, but I have a lot of wet flour.
Do you want to give him
a little tip?
Just rolling it up
gives it a good oven spring,
especially for, like,
this kind of shape.
I'm marbling my loaf, so I'm
putting together the two doughs.
Beautiful.
I decided to put quite a lot of
rye in it.
Yes, it's rye bread!
I know, but rye bread needs
lots of time to prove.
Who's going to announce my name?
Last week...
Er... Oh, it'll be Noel.
Last week, Jon, so...
Yeah, Noel has to say goodbye
to you. Yeah.
I'll go get him ready!
OK.
Yes!
Looking good.
The bakers will need to gauge when
their loaves are just baked through.
It's beautiful!
If they remove it too soon,
their bread will be doughy.
Too long, and the rye will be dry.
So, it's going to go
for half an hour.
Oh!
Can't really do anything now!
I've done my timings,
and it leaves me with about...
..25 minutes to cool, and about 15
minutes to put the toppings on.
I need half an hour to cool...
..ish.
If I bake it for half an hour,
that means three hours.
Yeah, I just have to...
No.
Yeah.
I don't really have much time.
Oldest flag in the world.
Danish. Really? That one there?
No, not this specific...
Bakers, you have one hour left!
Bakers' loaves are in the hands
of the oven gods.
Oh, dear.
In a matter of minutes, they'll
discover if their prove
will prove too much or too little.
It's about that much.
Ooh, that looks good!
That looks really nice.
It looks a bit different
to the one I did at home.
Oh, dear me.
Mm!
I'm happy.
Right, so the rise isn't actually
as much as I originally hoped.
It's actually quite small.
It'll be fine.
So now I'm going to let it cool.
How are you?
Are you doubting yourself?
I've got a baby loaf
compared to everyone else's.
A baby loaf? It's quite small.
How small?
About that, and it's not as...
Why don't you say
it's in the distance?
Kim-Joy, Ruby and Manon have allowed
their bread crucial cooling time...
I just hope they're not going to say
it doesn't look like a rye bread.
..but Briony and Rahul
are playing a dangerous game.
They'll have to cut their loaves
when they're still baking hot,
which will make cutting a thin slice
extremely tricky.
I think I have to take it out now.
It's just not ready yet.
I'm going to crumble now, because
I don't have time to cool now.
HE SIGHS
Come on.
Looks good.
Hot, hot, hot, but good, good, good.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes,
just 15 minutes.
Showtime.
My slices are quite thin,
but I thought that's what...
Yeah, you know what?
I'm going with what I'm going with.
In record time, the bakers will need
to work out how to transform
their Danish rye into
an exquisite open sandwich.
I'm going to do these,
and then I'm going to cut.
I think it's just not cooked enough.
Like, how do you make a sandwich
look good?
I just want to eat it!
I love a salmon sandwich.
So that's goat's cheese.
Bakers, you have five minutes,
just five minutes.
Oh, what am I doing?
It's probably a little bit thicker
than I was going for!
Going to be a bit of a
doorstop sandwich.
This is a home-made cheese I made.
How do you get this stuff
to look nice?
It has got a big stinger.
This is, like, a layer of
roasted butternut squash.
Where did I put my salad?
Let's get the swans on.
Oh!
Oh, no! My swans!
Oh, my little swans...
You know, they've looked better.
Bakers, you have one minute,
just one minute.
Oh, well.
Stop falling off.
Oh!
Let's get these on.
Oh, my hand is actually shaking.
I'm just worried that the egg
bumblebees look a bit dried out now.
That is the end.
You are out of time.
HE SIGHS
The bakers' smorrebrod face
quarterfinal judging
by Prue and Paul.
Hello, Ruby. Hello. Hello, Ruby. Hi.
Oh, God.
That's how thin it should
be and that, actually,
is the right structure.
That is nice. Mm.
Well done. That's what I expect.
I think that's a very good colour.
So, that's tandoori chicken and
some raita is sitting on the bottom
and some cucumber ribbons.
I think the flavour of that is good.
I think it works together
as a sandwich. OK.
Very well balanced. There's a
little bit of chilli there. Yeah.
I like it all.
And, what, this is the avocado on
there as well?
Yes, avocado, asparagus,
chorizo and quails' eggs.
It's a real celebration of rye,
particularly in that one.
Good. It's very good.
It's like the Mediterranean
meets Denmark. Thank you.
Well done. God, I'm sweating.
I'd like to have seen more
colour on it. OK. Inside, yeah?
Erm, and more dense and filled
with seeds, preferably. Yeah.
Right.
So we have goat cheese,
roasted beetroots,
some strawberries,
some glazed vinegar.
The flavour of your rye
is not strong.
Also, I think it lacks savouriness.
It's so sweet. OK, sweet. Uh-huh.
It almost needs seasoning,
doesn't it? It does.
Otherwise it's just like, erm...
Cheesy. ..pudding.
The chutney, the walnut, the cheese,
as a sandwich, it's great.
But as a Danish open sandwich?
Do you know what bread that is?
Pain de campagne. Oh, really?
Yeah, you've made a French loaf.
You've definitely got a rye
in there and it is baked well.
OK. And this is a very
beautiful looking texture.
I hope it tastes as good as that.
They are beautiful-looking
sandwiches.
The flavours are good.
I can really taste the rye.
I think the dill makes it authentic,
and so does the fish
and the avocado and the capers. Mm.
I just, it just needs to be a little
bit stiffer, more seeds
and I think you would've been
nearly there, to be honest.
Yeah, it was all right. It's fine.
Can you imagine, Prue... Yes.
..walking into a
little coffee shop?
Is that Prue walking?
Is that how she walks?
She walks in and says... Yes.
AS PRUE: "Excuse me, would you
mind making me a sandwich?"
So you turn round... Yeah.
..and give her that. Yeah.
To be honest with you, I just...
Yeah, I appreciate they're too big.
OK. I do apologise on that front.
They're too big. Yes.
Let's try and judge them anyway.
What is this? Chorizo, iberico ham
and sweet potato with a fig jam.
I tasted the white rye by itself
and it doesn't taste much of rye.
Right, OK.
It's more like a
malted loaf than a rye. OK.
This is even more difficult to...
Started building my
own sandwich here. Mm.
I would've thought the smoked
mackerel would've been perfect
but it's quite dry and... OK.
It's not rye enough,
it's not dense enough,
it's not at all like
an open sandwich bread.
So you're in another challenge.
It's a shame.
It's just gone really soggy.
It's so dense, it's almost
like a cake there.
There's no air holes in it at all.
But it does look, to be honest,
Rahul, a bit of a mess. Yeah.
Erm..
Oh, dear. Oh no.
Not for me, mate. The bread's awful.
It's actually turning back
into a dough in my mouth.
Paul is right, it's...
Very stodgy.
..very heavy and gluey.
It was the proving and you
know that. Yeah.
I knew that it was the proving.
Actually, that reminds me of
a flavour of a sandwich I had
in Copenhagen.
I'm avoiding eating the bread
because I don't think
it's entirely edible. Yeah.
I think you just did too much.
You tried too hard.
WHISPERS: It's OK.
They're really harsh today.
That's not bad, is it?
A real celebration of rye.
Cheers for that, Paul,
on a rye bread challenge.
I mean, what more could I want?
It just shows how bad it is
that Paul Hollywood
did not eat the bread
because it's so bad.
Yeah, it was not my best.
So I'm middle but
middle below kind of thing.
If I think that I felt like
my comments were the worst,
I think I'd be crying.
CRYING: That was a bit brutal.
That was harsh, yeah.
Get back up. Get back on it.
That's just who I am.
For the first challenge,
the bakers could practice
as much as they liked,
but they're going into
this second one blind.
Right, bakers, welcome back to
the Technical Challenge,
which today has been set
for you by Paul,
although I'm pretty sure he got
the idea from my house, just saying.
Paul, any advice? There's a
technique in this recipe
you're going to have to learn
and learn quickly.
Oh, wow. Right, thank you very much.
Off we go.
Now, for your Technical
Challenge today, Paul/Sandi,
would like you to make
14 Danish aebleskiver.
Your 14 aebleskiver need
to be perfect
with a distinctive spherical shape.
Your aebleskiver must be filled
with cinnamon spiced apple
and served with a
strawberry jam dipping sauce.
You have one hour for your
challenge.
On your marks... Get set... Bake!
Right, OK.
Ooh.
This looks fun.
So I actually know what they are.
Have I heard of these before? Nope.
Have I seen them before? Nope.
Paul, why aebleskiver?
I've never had one
and I've never made one
and I think they sound
incredibly difficult.
The best way to show you what an
aebleskiver is, is cut one open.
So what you have is
an aerated dough inside
and then you have this
pocket of apple and cinnamon.
You want these beautiful, smooth,
spherical pancakes, if you like.
It's a lovely, light batter,
isn't it?
Oh, yeah. Oh, it's delicious.
This is the tricky bit.
They've all got these metal plates
with indentations,
it's like semicircles.
What you've got to do is pour
this batter mixture in.
Once you see the edges firming up,
you've got to rotate it.
Once you rotate, you end up
with a hole in the middle
and this is where you put
your apple and cinnamon,
then you finally rotate and
the batter covers that.
Sounds hugely difficult.
I just hope for their sake
that they are cooked
cos Sandi's going to kick off,
big time.
Before making the
all-important batter,
the bakers have two
elements to rustle up.
What you doing now? Jam sugar.
I'm just making the apple now.
What's that? Looks like baby sick.
A delicious apple and cinnamon
filling and strawberry preserve.
How does that even work -
a jam dipping sauce?
Get it up to 105 degrees is
generally the best thing to do.
Briony's using a
thermometer in her jam.
Actually, she's taken hers off.
I'm going to take mine off
and leave it to cool now.
For the batter, whisk the egg
whites and sugar together.
It's not the same as a pancake
you'd have on Pancake Day,
like, it's got buttermilk in it.
It's a bit posh.
I think I'm looking for a
nice, smooth consistency,
something that's not too sloppy.
Are you happy with this?
I've actually seen it before.
You've seen it before?
Cos my sister dated a Danish
guy for, like, two years.
Your sister dated a Danish dude.
Yeah.
Sounds like a porn star, I'm not
going to lie, and he made this?
So you've seen it? Yeah.
Yeah, I've seen it before.
This is yours. Yeah, we'll see.
Don't want to knock out too much of
the air that I've just whisked in.
I'm going to guess it needs
to be nice and smooth.
I'm not very good
with time constraints.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
OK, I better get moving.
I'm going to go for it now.
Oh, my God, that's heavy.
Just greasing these balls.
I don't really know what I'm doing
but it just says, "Spoon
the batter into the holes
"until they are
three quarters full."
Is that three quarters full
or is that too full?
I'm just going to start
and learn as I go.
"Cook until the edges
begin to firm."
Begin to firm. So it's not
letting it cook fully.
"Turn the aebleskiver 90 degrees
using two wooden skewers."
Oh, it says 90 degrees.
Is 90 degrees like that?
Turning 90 degrees. So what does
it mean by turn it 90 degrees?
What do you think it means?
Turning, so I guess like that?
But that's 180 degrees, innit?
What does turn mean?
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Right, so you go like that.
"Spoon a little of the spiced apple
into the hole of the batter
"and then turn it another
90 degrees to close."
Really don't know how I'm meant
to be doing this but...
Oh, OK.
But there's no bloody hole
to put the thing in.
Oh, these are not going well.
Wow, that's hard. OK.
Wow, look, it's a little pancake!
Yeah, I mean, it's
a little spherical pancake
with apple stuff inside.
Uh-oh. Very quick, isn't it?
That's just not good at all.
Oh, I don't actually
have that much batter.
This is going to be quite
challenging, guys.
I have no idea what hole
you're talking about.
Oh. What hole?
What hole are we talking about?
SPEAKS IN DANISH:
Oh, no, no, no.
The whole thing's burnt.
I think it's just
the heat's too high.
I tried to reduce it but it's just
not working for me.
I'm going to have to
put the apple in somehow.
spoon it in afterwards.
They will never know.
Ouch!
I think I've lost some batter and
now they just look very, very small.
They're really cool.
Having never seen one before,
I'm thrilled.
Come at a bad time?
Yes, maybe, but that's fine.
We're trying to make you
proud, Sandi. Very good.
Doing our best.
I have no time for this nonsense.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
There's only five minutes left and
I have to finish seven of them.
What am I doing? Get in there.
I've got eight and how
many do we need? 14?
My aebleskiver are made,
so I'm just sieving through my jam
so it's super smooth.
Oh, it won't even get in there now.
It's literally horrible.
Going everywhere. Burnt.
Bakers, you have one minute.
That's not the best.
They're definitely not what
Sandi was looking for.
Thank God I had a
decent Signature, eh?
Bakers, that is the end.
Your time is up.
They're not looking good.
Please bring your aebleskiver
and place them behind your
photograph on the table.
Prue and Paul are expecting
14 perfect aebleskiver.
Spheres of light batter,
filled with cinnamon spiced apple,
accompanied by a
strawberry jam dipping sauce.
Interesting.
Right, shall we start with this one?
Mm-hm.
Hang on a minute. Yes.
Hang on a minute!
Now, these look as if they've
been torn open to be filled...
They have. ...like doughnuts,
you know?
Cutting it and putting apple in it
is not the way.
It's a bit stodgy. Someone
struggled really rotating them.
Mm.
Very nice cinnamon flavour
though and apple.
But the sauce is not
a dipping sauce.
Yeah, this is a bit too thick.
It's a shame.
Now, moving on, these
look a bit neater.
There's the apple filling.
Quite chunky apples, which I don't
really mind that much, to be honest.
It's good dipping sauce, that. Mm.
They're pretty good. It's quite
aerated, you can see from inside.
Mm. Just the right texture.
Mm. You've got a bit of bite there,
haven't you? Yeah.
Look at the colour,
the colour difference. Yeah.
They're not a perfect set.
They're not.
So if we go for one in the middle.
Little bit of aeration. Got a lot
of apple in there, actually.
Bit stodgy inside.
I like the amount of filling though.
It's rather good.
The strawberry dipping sauce
isn't too bad at all.
These have had serious issues.
It's split.
This is to do with the heat.
What's happened with this,
it's browned very quickly
without the batter cooking. Yeah.
You can taste the burnt
on that as well. Mm.
It's very like a burnt pancake.
Moving onto our last one.
Bit of a difference here in size.
Yeah.
Erm... Yeah, that one is a walnut
sized one. Look at that.
There's loads of apple
in there, Prue.
It's aerated enough, I just
think they struggled with the,
again, with the temperature
and the consistency.
OK.
Prue and Paul will now rate the
aebleskiver from best to worst.
In fifth, and last place, are these.
Rahul, you can taste the burntness.
Unlucky. Yeah.
In fourth place is this one.
Manon, they were sort
of all different sizes,
but they tasted good.
In third place is this one.
They were a little bit stodgy
but the overall appearance
is better than the other two. OK.
However, cutting them with a knife
and filling them with
a bit of apple sauce?
I could not understand
what hole you were talking about
so I was just, like,
just get it in there.
PRUE LAUGHS
So, in second place is...
..this one.
Kim-Joy, they were nice
and even.
Really they were a
pretty good shot at it.
Which means in first place...
Obviously you've got a nice bit
of aeration,
a good bit of apple in there
as well. The sauce is good.
Well done. Thanks, Paul. Thank you.
Yay!
It can be as stodgy all it likes,
I mean, it got me third place.
I didn't come last.
It's really bad.
NOEL: One last challenge.
A final chance for the bakers
to earn their place in the tent
and to claim Star Baker.
Can I just say?
I've loved having Danish Week.
Can I just say, for the record, when
are we having a Halloween Week?
You know, Horror Week? Cos,
you know, we've had Danish Week.
Every week that we look
at you, darling, every week.
I think, one week, we maybe
do a Goth Week. Goth Week, surely!
I think Goth Week.
Black fairy cakes.
So, all five bakers turned up
yesterday -
hilarious Hawaiian shirts,
very jolly
and I think, suddenly,
reality actually set in.
Yeah, it's semifinals next week.
We have to be slightly harder.
It's tight, isn't it?
I mean, we're talking about...
It is very, very close.
I mean, Ruby and Kim-Joy are both
in the Star Baker position
at the moment.
So Briony in the middle?
Briony's one of those people that
could leave or could be Star Baker.
It's a bit up and down.
Manon is a very French baker.
Look at that bread she made.
That bread, if it was French Week,
was perfect, but it wasn't right.
And Rahul, oddly,
is in a little bit of danger.
I think he's run out
of confidence.
He got hit hard
for the first time yesterday,
where we were quite
critical about his baking.
Genuinely, I do not know today
whose gonna get the crown
and who's gonna go home.
No. None of us do.
Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
For your Showstopper Challenge
today, Paul and Prue would like you
to make kagemand, or kagekone.
Kagemand, or kagekone,
is a cake traditionally served at
a birthday celebration in Denmark,
so the cake is shaped like
a boy or a girl
and the best bit is that the whole
party is supposed to scream
when the head gets cut off.
Oh, I love that.
LAUGHTER
OK. Your kagemand
must be perfectly baked
using yeasted Danish pastry
and must be intricately decorated.
And as if that wasn't enough,
your decoration is to include
at least three different
confectionary making skills.
You have four and a half hours.
On your marks... Get set...
Bake!
TIMERS BEEP
The bakers must make their kagemand,
or kagekone, in the form of
somebody recognisable to them, give
or take a little artistic license,
and, just as they do in Denmark,
create it from
delicious Danish pastries.
What I would like to see
is Danish pastry that is
actually filled and then glazed
so that it's a little bit shiny.
So, shiny, delicious,
sweeties on top...
Mm, lovely.
You want a golden, flaky pastry,
beautiful and soft inside,
and luxurious butter layers.
I think Danish pastry's
a great way to test the bakers.
They have to get that
Danish pastry right.
NOEL: To be master of their
Danish pastry,
the bakers must achieve
perfect lamination...
It's pretty satisfying.
..the creation of delicate layers
of butter within the dough.
Et voila!
BRIONY: So you want to keep the
butter as cold as possible
for this to work. Cos if not,
then it all melts out.
Over the next few hours...
Oh, it's just taking ages.
..the bakers repeatedly roll,
fold and chill
to create a perfect dough,
which, in a searing tent...
I'm so hot.
..will be easier said then done.
That's just one fold done.
One of four.
Good morning. Hello, Briony.
What about your birthday cake?
So I'm doing my Nana Pat,
as she's an amazing woman.
She's 93. Still touches her toes
every morning and she...
I can't do that now.
I know. Neither can I.
Is this her picture?
Yeah, sorry.
This is her on
her wedding day in 1948.
She looks lovely.
But I'm doing her in the 1940s.
Nice square shoulders.
Yes, nice square shoulders.
Nice nipped in waist with her belt.
She was just very glam
and she still is a very cool lady.
Nana Pat will be accessorised with
toffee heels and a sherbet handbag.
Briony's traditional Danish swirls
will have a novel filling of
blueberries with
a ginger creme patissiere.
Nana Pat has tried this.
She gave me the big thumbs up.
She's just amazing.
Still drives.
Oh, my God.
Look, it's literally walking.
If you got through to the semis,
would you be really excited?
Yeah!
Mega excited. Imagine getting
through to the final.
Oh, my God.
I can't even think about it.
I mean, I'm not even sure
I'm getting through to the final.
It's touch and go for me.
So I'm doing a kagekone, I think
they call it, and that is my sister.
She was a gorgeous child!
And there's a picture of her
at my brother's birthday
and they looked like they
were having the most amount of fun,
so it's modelled on her.
To make sister Nic picture-perfect,
Ruby is assembling her
Danish by Danish,
and covering each one with
a neat circle of marzipan
before adding her
confectionary clothes.
The marzipan's just sitting on top
of the frangipane Danish? Danish.
Yeah.
Will you be able to see the Danish?
No. I can show some of it
if it needs to.
Don't let him put you off.
I'm trying to not let him
get in my head. He's making me...
Look at me. Look at me.
..doubt everything again.
Ignore. Ignore. Yeah. No.
Just look at me. I've got you.
Good, good. Good luck.
He's not doing that to me today.
Marshmallows.
Whoa. I'm gonna be sticky.
I'm so sticky.
I'm just making my marshmallow.
Hopefully.
Looks a little bit runny at the
minute, but we'll see how it goes.
NOEL: This Showstopper's
been designed to test
a whole range of skills.
It's gone quite gelatinous.
It's no good.
To earn a place in the semifinal,
the bakers must produce
more individual elements
then ever before.
Ouch. I can't afford to lose
any single minute today.
So many things that you
really want to get right today.
Basically everything.
I believe in you.
You know, like...
Have you seen Star Wars?
No. You're Luke Skywalker now
and I'm Yoda.
What are you talking about?
HE IMITATES YODA:
Strong in the baking, are you!
Who is Luke Sidewalker?
Have you seen... Who? Luke who?
Luke what? Sky...?
Skywalker. Oh, I don't know.
He's a Jedi.
You were too busy probably,
studying science,
while I was pretending to be a Jedi.
Rahul may not want to be a Jedi,
but today he will be
the King of India -
bejewelled with fruit jellies
and handmade chocolates on top of
his traditional Danish.
So, basically, twisted knots and
then filled it with creme pat.
And then the whole thing will be
covered with marzipan
and then I'm gonna
put a layer of buttercream. Wow.
Hang on. On top of the Danish
pastry, which is gonna be crispy,
you're covering that
with buttercream?
The only reason being, sometimes
because of the Danish shape,
it can be a little bit up and down.
Remember - celebrate the Danish.
One baker is celebrating their
Danish by stripping it right back.
I'm actually going for
quite a plain Danish pastry.
I don't like...
I just like to eat
just the pastry on its own.
So that's why I just
wanted to do plain croissant.
OK, I think it's gonna be enough.
Manon's recreating her friend Stina.
She's going above and beyond,
decorating with four types
of confectionary and showing off her
French patisserie skills by adding
pain au chocolat arms and legs.
What butter are you using?
So I'm using Danish butter.
Yes.
Why do you look like that, Paul?
It's not a go-to butter
professionally that you'd use...
..ever. It's French.
You should have gone French...
Really? ..with the butter. Yeah.
It has a higher melting temperature.
So when you're developing
the dough... OK.
..they don't melt as much.
Can I just say, Paul?
This is no time to tell her this.
She has made her pastry. Yeah.
I'll just do this really quickly.
I know it's really warm in here.
It's not ideal.
Ooh!
Paul's gonna be very watchful
over the layers, over everything,
so you've just got to work quickly,
but not to the detriment
of the dough, really.
I need to relax.
I'm so stressed.
I don't know what I'm doing now.
Hang on a minute.
So this is my crystallised ginger,
which I'm putting into
the honeycomb.
Honeycomb covered in chocolate
is one of my sister's favourite...
..chocolates.
With half the bake gone
and time of the essence,
the bakers must decide
where to focus their energies.
While Ruby, Manon and Rahul are
concentrating on their sweets...
I've got white chocolate
for my ganache.
SHE EXHALES
Chocolate rain.
..Briony and Kim-Joy
are prioritising decoration.
I'm not gonna lie, it's not an
exact representation of Nana Pat.
I can't mess it up,
otherwise Charlotte will go,
"Why am I getting a face like that?"
Oh, she's starting to come to life?
Yes, she's a living, living lady.
Oh, look at that face!
It's gorgeous. It's quite creepy.
Do you paint?
It is a little on the creepy side.
In real life, Kim-Joy's friend
Charlotte isn't at all creepy,
she's an opera buff
and will be dressed to impress
in an elegant ball gown.
I like intricate stuff.
I like being able
to take my time over it.
What is this bit, then?
So this, I'm just doing her
skirt... Right. ..and her top.
So I'm just putting on the base
and putting little roses on it.
OK. I'm being very stupid,
is this cooked already?
This is just marzipan.
Oh, it's marzipan. OK.
Looked like very underdone dough.
Can you tell how much I've learnt
in the time I've spent in the tent?
Yes! Yes. I can tell.
You are... Yeah.
What are you doing in there?
Sorting out my truffles.
That one's a bit sad, isn't he?
Which one? This one?
Yeah. No, the one at the back.
It's a bit small.
Yeah, it's a little baby one. Is it?
Is he gonna like that, Paul? He'll
go, "They're not the same size."
It is a competition.
He is the judge.
It's up to you, though.
Go your own way. Fine.
What you doing?
Making them all a bit smaller.
Don't listen to me!
You got in my head.
Bakers, you have two hours left.
Doomed.
Do you want a bit of herring?
Hmm?
Herring? Do you want some herring?
I've got something stuck
in my teeth.
OK, so I just need to think,
because obviously I need to
have enough dough for all of it.
Oh. As you can see,
I am a little bit stressed.
Ready or not, the bakers
must now shape their Danishes...
I'm gonna turn this
into twisted knots.
One leg.
..to ensure they don't
run out of time for proving,
baking and cooling.
I'm just really conscious that
I want them to be nice, tight rolls.
So these bigger ones
will be more so for the body.
I should... I think I need about 17.
I have to make one head.
Obviously. Humans have one head.
Yes, I really don't want
to make the head too big
cos it is gonna rise.
Just doing Nana Pat's hair.
Oh, gone way too big!
SHE LAUGHS
I just need to finish it
as soon as possible
because I actually need to prove it.
The bakers face
a critical decision -
how long to prove their dough?
If it's not given long enough, the
pastry will be too heavy and dense.
Too long and they risk
the butter leaking out.
I'm probably gonna give them half
hour. They haven't got much time.
That looks like Operation.
Do you know Operation? The game?
The game! Oh, yes.
You have to... Yeah.
We call it Docteur Maboul.
What's that mean?
That means "crazy doctor".
Crazy doctor? Yes.
God, I'm so hot.
I just wonder if I should
just, you know, bake it.
It's just so hot in here and...
..yeah, I think I should
just bake it.
Kim-Joy's friend has been
proving for 15 minutes.
It's so hot in here,
I'm already gonna lose lamination.
I'm just gonna bake it now.
I'm just filling
my chocolate bon bons
and then I'm gonna put it
in the freezer for a little bit.
Tastes like sherbet.
SHE COUGHS
Once this is done, I have
made my marshmallow, my caramel.
I only have to do
my chocolate and my nougatine.
Nana Pat is in.
Don't move. Don't move. Please
don't move. Please don't move.
Oh, OK.
So they're going in
now for 15 minutes.
Danish pastry requires a short bake.
In a matter of minutes, the bakers
will know if their hours of
tireless work have been in vain.
You don't want it to brown too much
on the outside, but you want it to
cook nicely on the inside
so you've got to be careful.
They look really flaky and puffy.
Look, there's lots
of butter leaking.
Oh, dear me.
The pain au chocolat
has opened a little bit.
A lot of pressure.
OK.
It looks really flaky and gigantic.
Erm, it's not as...
It's not as delicate and small
as I thought it would be.
Just got to...
..make it work.
Ah!
I haven't even got a sword.
Well, that's not my fault. Ah!
Ooh.
Ooh. Do the time call.
Bakers...
SHE WHISPERS: One hour.
..you've got one...
..hour...
..left.
And you've got less.
I'm loving this week.
I'm loving it.
I'm gonna open the door.
These are looking good.
Maybe a little bit crispy
round the outside, but...
..yeah, I'm happy with those.
Lovely, lovely lamination.
It's a nice colour, it's a nice
golden brown. So, happy with that.
I think this has
risen in a weird way.
It's crispy on the top,
but very bready inside.
I'm just worried it's still
gonna be a bit doughy inside.
Come on, Manon.
Ah.
Tiny bit more.
Literally, like, two minutes.
Come on. Last effort.
Gonna wait till this...
The main thing is that it's out
and it's cooked and I like it
and it's good.
We'll just cover it with raspberries
on the top and, you know,
it'll all be distracted.
I'm just gonna put it
for another five minutes
and then I'm just gonna take it
out.
Can I taste this bit? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Go for it. Are you sure?
That bit's probably
a bit crunchy, but...
..but, yeah.
Mm!
That is delicious.
Good. Wow.
Come on.
Smells like something's burning.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Tried your best and that's it.
OK. That is coming out.
Ah!
Bakers, you have 15 minutes,
just 15 minutes.
Go, go, go.
Shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo.
OK.
This is the leg.
It's hard to make a big slab
of pastry look good.
Victory rolls have gone a bit wonky.
Ta-dah!
We've got this, OK?
Oh, wow. Great.
It's not going to work how I want
to work, but I'll just have to
do it now, in whatever way I can.
Well, it's not as good
as I wanted it to look.
The braid is just... Yeah, just need
to arrange things cleverly.
She likes to wear a lot
of bright colours.
Believe it or not, I'm actually
the quietest in my house.
Beautiful.
It's the two hands of the maharajah.
I like fresh raspberries.
Yeah, all right. She's coming
together, she's coming together.
Oh, dear me.
My hands are shaking so bad,
I can't even bloody cut.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Urgh, bah!
Scissors? Scissors? Scissors?
Scissors? Scissors anywhere?
Belt, face.
Bag. Ooh, toffee, toffee, toffee.
After this, I'm going home.
Breaking it into pieces
cos it will sit on my skirt.
Ah, yes. That was so satisfying.
I'm not sure how proud she'd
be of this pearl necklace,
but she's getting it.
These are with raspberry jam.
I guess they look like feet,
really, don't they?
Maybe I should keep them as feet?
Doesn't really look that good.
That's it. Oh, BLEEP.
Right, bakers, your time is up.
Please place your Showstoppers
at the end of your work stations.
It's rubbish, but it's OK.
The bakers' Danish Showstoppers
now face the judgment
of Paul and Prue.
Ruby, please bring up your kagekone.
And this is your sister?
This is my sister
when she was younger.
She's got a very fun,
bubbly personality.
It's absolutely sweet.
Aw. It really is.
The Danish pastries look
like Danish pastries.
See the layers,
how tight they are together.
There's butter still in there.
It's crispy on the outside.
If you'd glazed it,
it would have been nicer.
Oh, really? With apricot jam.
Apricot jam? Apricot jam.
Right, OK. Fine.
I think the pastry's lovely
but Paul is right
about the apricot glaze.
Not just for its look...
Yeah, for the taste.
..but because you need a little
bit more sweetness in it. OK.
But it's buttery. I can
feel that on my tongue.
Yeah. You have your honeycomb.
Mm. Yeah, the ginger works.
That's delicious. Thank you.
Overall, I think it's really nice.
I think the design's effective.
It's really nice.
Yeah, simple and effective.
I must say, I think that the way
that you've done the skirt
with the plaiting of the
marshmallow,
and the face, and the bow on top,
is all beautifully done. Lovely.
So, what filling have you
put inside your Danish?
So I just have a bar of chocolate
and the rest is just plain.
I like it plain.
Hmm, is that a Danish or
is that a pain au chocolat?
One, two, three.
THEY SCREAM
THEY LAUGH
It is a little
undercooked in the middle
and overcooked on the outside.
Your oven was too high and you
kept it in there for too long.
The first thing that happens
in a Danish pastry
is butter leaks away
from the Danish,
soaks onto the tray, gets drawn
up from the bottom of the pastry
and that flashes with the heat.
And it fries at the bottom.
The bottom's fried. Yeah. So that's
what's happened there. Yeah.
And it's not just happened on this,
it's happened on all of them.
I mean, that's been sitting in
a pool of butter
and now it's solidified.
It's congealed.
And these chocolates.
Mm. It's good.
The sweets are very, very good.
Very professional looking, actually.
Your pastry, however,
I have a big issue with.
I think your baking
was pretty poor on this.
Thank you.
I don't think I've ever seen
more exquisite piping.
Thank you. It's amazing.
Um, so it represents
my friend Charlotte
and it's her wearing, like, a gown.
The design of it is impeccable.
I mean, it's very, very good.
However, for me, you've
had issues with the butter.
It's all gone. Yeah. It's dry.
You see the big gaps?
That's where the
butter's gone. Ah.
So what you're left
with is just the dough.
It's definitely, sort of,
underbaked or soggy.
You've under-proved this thing.
I think I worried that, um,
it was quite warm
so the butter might
be getting too warm,
so I baked it sooner.
Hmm.
Shall we do the other filling?
This one. Hmm.
What have you got in that, um...?
Is that creme pat? Mm-hmm.
What's in there? Um, with...
Almond liqueur creme pat?
Mm.
It's OK. It's OK.
It's very nice and strong.
I love that.
Marzipan's good, chocolate's good.
The jellies are nice.
The pastry, not so.
Mm-hm.
Thank you, Kim-Joy.
Thank you very much.
Can I help you? Let me help you.
It's OK, sweet. It's all right.
You did great. It looks beautiful.
I'm good now. I'm fine.
Just let it out.
SHE LAUGHS AND SNIFFLES
In the Danish pastries,
you've got ginger creme pat
with some dried blueberries.
And then it's got vanilla marzipan,
and then there's some sherbet
and some toffee on her
shoes at the bottom,
and a marshmallow necklace as well.
It's not a beard!
It's a necklace.
It's got a lovely flavour. Oh, good.
Mm. I quite like the blueberries
in there and the colour's nice.
See the colour? That's the colour
you're looking for. Good.
And this just sherbet, is it?
Yes, that's sherbet on the bag, yep.
BRIONY LAUGHS
It is, yeah. It's good, isn't it?
Overall, it's got a nice flavour.
You're the closest one
to get the Danish pastries.
It's just burnt.
You left it in the oven
ten minutes too long.
Probably, yeah. Just... Yeah.
But I love the way you've used
the round ones for the buttons
and it looks positively
Indian and jewelled.
Uh-oh, here we go. Are you ready?
THEY SCREAM
Bring this over.
It's tough.
And very dry. Hm.
Really dry.
Um, marzipan's lovely.
Very nice. It's got a nice flavour.
Shall we have a jelly sweet?
Yeah.
Perfect. Ooh, yeah.
Very nice.
And that one is summer mixed berry.
That's nice, too.
And the hard buttons are basically,
uh, filled with raspberry jam.
Mm.
Well, I love all of your sweets.
Yeah.
The pastry is a bit disappointing.
Thank you, Rahul.
Yeah, thank you.
I need a hug.
Stop saying that. Everyone...
No, no, no, Rahul.
Don't say that yet, OK?
I don't deserve to be here any more
so I just need to be kicked out.
I don't know if I can talk about it.
SHE SNIFFLES
Hmm...
It's fine.
SHE SNIFFLES
There's been a lot of movement,
hasn't there?
I mean, in terms of the rankings.
I think some did better than others.
I think Briony's picked herself back
up. I also think Ruby's done well.
I think Kim-Joy's slipped down...
..in contention of leaving,
as well as Manon and Rahul...
are in serious trouble. In trouble.
Yes, I mean,
Manon did spend, for me,
far too much time making
beautiful sweets
and not enough time
filling her pastry,
which would have made a huge
difference. What about Rahul?
He burnt it, basically, yeah.
If you overbake a pastry
and all the butter runs out...
I think I know who's going to be
Star Baker.
We need to talk about that.
But who's going home?
You guys have another cup of tea?
I'll put the kettle on.
I've got a bottle of fizz
for myself.
Right, my lovely bakers,
I have loved Danish Week.
I thought it was great.
And I have the pleasure of
announcing the Star Baker.
This is getting harder and harder,
but there can only be one,
like there can only be one mermaid
in Copenhagen Harbour.
So the Star Baker this week is...
..Ruby!
OTHERS CHEER
Aww. Oh, man.
That means that I've got
the horrible job
of sending one of you home, and...
Yeah, this is going
to be a nightmare.
The person who's leaving us
this week is...
..Manon.
It's OK.
What?
Manon, you know what?
You should be proud of yourself.
I mean, to get this far is amazing.
SHE SIGHS
WHISPERS: It's going to be OK.
Oh, Manon.
It's just baking.
You did really well, Manon.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you.
Ironically,
it was on a pain au chocolat.
SHE LAUGHS
I've learned so much,
so many things I didn't even think
I would be able to actually make.
I'm a stronger... stronger baker,
and hopefully a stronger person.
PRUE: I am sad to see Manon go.
She's a really good French baker.
She's just not a very good
Danish one.
Next week, Rahul,
start upping it up.
I'll try. I promise I'll try.
I didn't expect that.
Just... Just, like... Yeah.
Congratulations.
Thank you. Thank you.
It sounds so silly in my head
that I've reached the semifinals.
Like, what?
See you next week. Oh, my God.
Well done, Ruby. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
Ruby's done it. I'm very happy
for her.
If there was a time to get Star
Baker, this is when to get it,
going into the semifinals.
It gees you up.
I got Star Baker!
CHEERING THROUGH SPEAKERPHONE
I told you, I'm the quiet one.
I told you I'm the quiet one.
Next week...
..as the end of the competition
draws nearer...
Semifinal, semifinal,
semifinal, semifinal. Aaagh!
..the bakers take
on Patisserie Week...
Fwe, fweel, fwee, feuilletine.
..with a deceptively difficult
Signature...
There's no time to even breathe.
..a lavishly layered Technical...
I don't know what I'm doing.
..and an epic
five-hour Showstopper...
He can say what he wants to say.
..to reach the final...
No, it's not good.
..of The Great British Bake Off.
HE PANTS
Subtitles by Red Bee Media